welcome everyone to our coffee talk
although depending on where you are
it's either happy hour which is most
likely
um or coffee so um if you can
grab your favorite drink and come join
and chat with us
my name is dorothy lee and i'm the vp
of business intelligence with aws
i've had the privilege
to be part of amazon for over 20 years
although if you would ask me
[Music]
if you would interview myself 20 years
ago i would have told you
that never in my wildest dreams i would
have thought that amazon would have
such a deep impact in our both our
personal
and work lives or that i would be here
for this long and still having fun
doing my job um so you know today
this is really our time together to have
um a casual conversation about what it's
like to work at amazon what's different
about
amazon um what are the challenges
facing all of us as women whether you're
new to the workplace or just starting
out or your mid-career
and more importantly we want you to be
part of it participate
ask us questions share
whatever the challenges you have
especially
in this in this environment where
everything's virtual a lot of us have to
wear
lots of different hats so so again this
is
meant to be a casual conversation share
anything
ask your questions in chat or raise your
hand
we really appreciate you being here and
spending time with us
so let's begin let's start with just an
introduction
of my colleagues here and talk about
a little bit about yourself um your
career progression and maybe a little
bit of
fun fact about you i'll start with
tatiana
thank you dorothy so my name is tatiana
and unlike dorothy i've joined amazon
only last year
uh and prior to joining amazon i've
worked at some other large companies
including microsoft and tableau
as well as like small companies
and i work in the same organization as
dorothy
i'm very passionate about helping people
analyze their data and
see and find those insights in the data
and i'm very happy to join amazon
tiffany this is good because
we have not i should just show some of
your profile we've not really known each
other this will be a really good
conversation for us
yeah it's great getting to know you guys
more too over this call
hey everyone i'm tiffany i am on the
aurora my sql team
i joined out of college actually as a
software engineer
and i've been on the team for seven
years so it's been an incredible journey
a really fun experience from joining the
team before the project was launched to
where we are today as the fastest
growing service in amazon
right i'm kathy
hi i'm kathy ninas and i'm on the same
team as tiffany
although i came from a different route i
had 20 plus years
at another large it tech company ibm
where i joined as a college hire there
and i spent
my development time doing everything
from low level firmware
up to owning and directing the the
mainframe storage systems that
connected around the world um and before
i left i was in their
machine learning watson health so i'm a
you know
a varied path lots of different
technology i joke that technology is my
hobby people are my passion
i came to amazon because a couple of
former colleagues kept
asking me to consider it and
um you know after a conversation with
with the amazonians i knew i wanted to
be part of the team
so i've been here for two and a half
years uh been able to take
aurora from infant service up to its
maturing five-year anniversary
and a fun fact i met my my husband at
officer basic so i was in the military
that's how i paid for my college
oh wonderful awesome
and where are you based actually just
where are you or um
i'm in seattle tatiana's in seattle
tiffany where
are you i'm in california our office is
in palo alto but
i'm in my home in sunnyvale right now
and i spend most of my time out of the
palo alto office but i am currently in
southern california
right anu
hi i am i have been with
amazon for four years i am currently
working
in amazon time stream database
trying to get that to a ga
prior to that i have been in alexa i
have been in
s3 so yeah and prior to joining in
amazon i have been a manager
in several other telecommunications
companies loose and technologies ribbon
communications
and i think i really like about amazon
is the scale
at which we operate you know and s3 was
one of the
biggest services that i've ever worked
on
i think the one of the biggest services
in the industry
and the problems that i faced there and
the kind of things that we had to do
really i think expanded the way we think
and
that's one of the reasons i am really
excited about uh working at amazon
and now i'm trying to build a similar
kind of a service uh hopefully we will
get to that level
uh in my latest job yeah yeah
thank you now we've had um i guess
tiffin and i joined tiffany you joined
amazon right after college i joined
amazon about two years so
you know almost like right after college
although i've you know i have to warn
you you could be here
for the next 20 years and still having a
lot of fun
um and the tatiana kathy and anu you've
all
had experience working at small and big
companies
and so um we all have had a lot of
experiences working at different types
of jobs different types of roles
and companies what is what's something
about
amazon that really stands out you know
or
you know maybe you can think about a you
know leadership principle for those of
you that
don't know amazon has a set of codify
leadership principles
that um that is really defines our
culture so what is
something different what's the
leadership principle that really
resonates with you
so for me the one thing that resonates
with me is i uh
initially in my career i work for big
companies you know loosening
technologies at t
bed labs um several different versions
of
the telecommunications companies tend to
be big
and also you know have a lot of
resources but also a little bit of a
bureaucracy and a process
uh then uh and i also work for mac which
is a pharmaceutical company which is
also again vegan
very heavy on process after that i
switched to a starter company
also telecommunications better that you
know we were in the startup and i really
enjoyed that uh you know more quick
thinking wise for action having a lot
more responsibility than i would
when working and a lot more direct uh
you know ability to do things
what i what struck me with amazon is you
get better at both worlds you are a huge
corporation with a lot of resources
and you know and ability to get things
done
um but you're also working in a small
and nimble teams
where you do have a lot of
responsibility and ability to
kind of get things turned around quickly
and deliver
results to our customers so i think that
that customer obsession
if you want to talk about a specific
leadership principle
i think that's one of the things that
exemplifies amazon
sets it apart from everybody else and
you think that stands it apart
anyone else wants to think i also want
to mention like
that customer obsession for me is
is my favorite leadership principle for
several reasons like first of all i like
helping customers
so every day i'm working and doing
something i know it matters to
peop other people and also what it helps
me is
day to day when there is some situation
we are trying
having discussion like design how to
build this software
like go this route versus that route
because i know that my peers are also
customer obsessed
when we have this dialogue and trying
trying to find
like the right solution i know that we
have
common foundation and it's not it never
feels to me that
like we are competing against each other
it's just like we have shared goal
and we are doing the best thing and
that it helps a lot right at the end of
the day
you all have the customer in mind and
that reminds me one of my
former bosses has always said
at every meeting just remember there's
an
empty seat who's our real boss and
that's the customer
at that scene and think about all our
discussions the decision made on behalf
of that
person that really is at the seat at the
at the
head of the table if you will yeah
exactly and if you call
any amazonian at any hour of the day for
a customer related issue they're there
to help you and
that's not something i always saw at
other companies
yeah tiffany do you want to share
or yeah i was all three of them
the customer obsession is definitely the
one that stands up and
and not just uh in addition to
everything that they said one thing
that also just really stands out is that
i think it helps you build a better
product i think tatiana touched on that
but when you think about what you're
building
from the engineer's perspective you're
not just trying to
to make something you're trying to think
about what works best for the customer
what are customers looking for
and i think that really helps you think
think big and
figure out something that that works
really well
that's a really good point and i i uh
noticed i knew you said you had worked
at
alexa right alexa
yeah yeah yeah right and one of the
things i
love about alexa which really
talks to that customer obsession how
that makes a better product
is that when you think about the
technology that's in
alexa um the key pieces of
of its technology the natural language
processing
um the something of something called far
field sensing which is that
that's the technology that allows you to
speak to alexa from one corner of the
house to another without
shouting and
of course the server technology that's
delivering
music and all of that none of that was
by itself
new yeah but what we did
was really work backwards from the
customer and then integrate these
technology
into a pretty innovative product and i
think
so through that lens you can do to your
point of view i think it's really a
it's one of the i think one of the
superpowers of
one of the key you know secret
ingredients if you will of
for our product development um i want to
share
one um leadership actually it's one
sort of cultural things that we do that
may not be
as obvious from the outside and this is
the thing
what i actually what um what most of us
say
to be able to the ability to disconfirm
our own bias and it's not something
that's
actually maybe the leadership principle
that we talk about here is is is deliver
results but when you think about it the
thing that
really allows all of us to be able to
deliver results one of the key
ingredients
is that we're able to really seek the
truth
to just confirm all of us have a lot of
bias about whether what we have
is right and to be able to just confirm
our own bias in other words you don't
you won't really hear we say
socialize an idea right because
it's kind of a condescending one to say
hey it
implies that my idea is right i just
need you to get on board
um why you could be completely wrong if
i talk to you so
we never say socialize an idea or we
shouldn't say that and so that's one of
the things that i think could be very
different from other companies
which is something i wanted to share it
also resonates with me
a lot of the leadership principles
resonates me as how
almost you know how i uh think about
life in general and maybe that's why
also i've been able to be here for so
long
and that really resonated with me as
well dorothy
when i when i came because i wasn't used
to getting a lot of feedback
and it wasn't that the people were
attacking my idea or me
they were working to make the best
solution for the customer
and i really do think that that cultural
difference
makes a difference in our end product
yeah
that's um that's absolutely true
now i'll throw i'll talk about something
um
that may that may be a perception on how
we
how um some of the challenges we made we
may face
so uh i know for myself
part of this disconfirming and part of
the the drive to seek the truth requires
me to speak up
and i have it's it's one of the
sort of obstacles that i've had to
overcome
in my own personal career and my own
just the way i am because i tend to be
i'm not as much of a
extrovert i tend to be in fact i tend to
be
less confrontation seeking this is also
not i guess it's not about
seeking confrontation but i tend my
natural tendency is not to speak up
so over the years i've really had to
um really overcome my tendency
to be quiet in meetings and to be able
to really speak up because this really
makes a difference for what i believe in
or to be able to get the truth across
and so that was something
a career obstacle that i had to overcome
and i wanted to ask
what were some of these things that you
guys have had to
overcome and what was some help that
you've been able to get
um along the way yeah i think
i that resonates with me you know i had
a similar kind of
uh i think i would say personality one
of the things that i really like about
amazon in specific
is the uh the focus that is given to
writing
right because not all of us are
communicate the same way
not all of us are extrovert uh you know
personalities
so the focus on amazon where we know
most of the meetings and
for folks who are outside of the amazon
we go into a meeting and we read
a document right so basically so this
is the most importance is given to the
data
and the you know instead of a
presentation or how
uh you know you were able to convince
others even
you were able to convince others by
actual presenting the data
you know the hot truths and you know how
the customer
benefit those are the things that we are
looking for so i think that's one of the
ways where i think amazon kind of brings
people together so
if you are not a very good speaker you
still have a you know space if you are
able to actually present the data
and the focus is not again on a
beautifully written document in fact
amazon actually says that
stick to the facts no use need for
flavory language or you know hyperbole
you know
none of that stuff just stick to the
facts and the data
and that's how and it should speak for
itself and the customer benefit
ultimately that is going to drive
everything that we do
so i think that's one of the things i
really like about amazon
and as you have done so in your career i
had to also kind of learn to speak up
uh and and and i think the preparation
actually helps
in that way when you have all your data
in front of you you have put
that effort in then you're also able to
confidently
speak up and actually kind of defend
your positions or absorb the other
data much more quickly yeah so i think
that's what i really like about amazon
yeah
great great point one of my colleagues
pointed out
that the way we um that this
writing culture and that takes the
personality out of it and this
data-driven culture actually is one of
the ultimate diversity
inclusion tools
you're letting that your words
and your critical thinking and data do
the talking and taking that personality
out of the way so um
others obstacles you want to share how
you overcame it any help
you got along the way the obstacle that
i want to share
is that
in the last few years i've made brave
not
perfect to be my motto in life because
uh i feel that earlier in my career like
i often was
trying to be perfect in everything and i
was taking
assignments to challenges when i already
had an
idea of how i'm going to execute on it
how i'm going to be successful
and if there was something like
challenging and unusual like
i would spend months uh thinking in
order thinking about that idea
but over time i've learned that actually
it's fine to
like sometimes fail but like you just
learn faster
like if you are brave if you're like
taking those challenging assignments
like you're not confident you're not
sure that you can be successful but
just go for it do your best and then at
the end of the day like
if some things don't work out like you
you know you've done your best like
you don't need to grill yourself about
it uh but just like
don't hold back do the best you can
yes thank you tatiana and i just wanna
we're almost
halfway in i just want to uh remind
everyone who's listening and joining
that um
feel free to ask your questions uh in
the chat window this is the time
for you so ask us anything
cathy and tiffany anything to add
yeah uh one thing for me was the
imposter syndrome
which i think is really common for women
in in such a male-dominated field
i remember my very first promotion from
sde-1 testy2
my manager and his manager said tiffany
we want to talk to you
so we went into the room and i was so
nervous i was like oh no like what what
did i do wrong what happened what are
they talking to me about
and when i went into the room they said
oh we are promoting you to an sd too
and it was just so funny because it was
the complete 180 of what i was expecting
um but that's one thing to to and and
what to
a new set as well to get that confidence
um
and you get that a lot from just getting
the data the numbers and
i i think um for me that's something
that i've been able to overcome just by
working with those around me
it is a male dominated field but i think
our team is really supportive
and and really helpful so i've had a
really good time
uh in my my experience here
and and i i think you know what tiffany
says the team is very supportive very
helpful
willing to give you feedback willing to
help you learn um
i like that it's a culture where you can
say i don't know
and you know if somebody does they're
gonna they're gonna help you they're
gonna give you advice
we learn from our mistakes i i think the
process we have in place here is
tremendous at
objectively looking at how could we have
done it better
and that we share that openly across the
organization
so that you can learn from others you
know
every week i'm learning something new
from a different team yes
um but this is i'm gonna um ask
a kind of question someone had asked me
a while back
which is you know if you would
if we would go back to ourselves
when we first started out what advice
would we give to ourselves back then
or even um or if you're changed thinking
about changing jobs what advice would we
have given ourselves when we were
changing jobs
when we thinking about career changes
i'll i'll start um
since someone asked me it's unfair
someone had asked me this question a
while ago i had to actually
prepare this answer um
one of the things i um i learned later
on
only from my um current boss is
that when you're thinking about taking
on something risky
um there's usually three types of risks
and there is a technology risk right
this might be something that's never
been done
uh unproven you don't know that it's
going to be successful from a technology
perspective
there's a product market fit perspective
you might even have something that's
groundbreaking but it's
ahead of its time and the third one
would be a people risk
so you might have a team um
who you might not maybe brilliant but
not
may not do really well together and by
the way these are also you know sort of
the kinds of risks you think about as we
you know you think about doing a startup
as well
and you can take two out of the three
ricks and you don't want to take all
three ricks you could just three
all three risks you can take two of the
three risks even
but of the risks that you take you
should never
take that people risk because everything
else
in other words everything else
um you could either mitigate or maybe
you cannot really control
but the people are at the heart of what
makes a company great
and you absolutely want to be working
with great people you admire
and people that you care that care about
you
as well so that would be my advice
to my younger self and say hey as you're
thinking about changing careers
absolutely know the person that you're
going to be working with or working for
don't take that risk
it doesn't mean you don't work with new
people it's just that you really need to
really understand
do they do they have similar values with
you do they see
things you know are you going to be able
to work well together
yeah i think that's a great point right
and i think
that's where i think leadership
principles really help
when you are making a decision for a
working for a company
like amazon right because it's not a
small company
it's not uh you know if you're applying
for a job here probably you wouldn't
know
uh probably you may have a lot of
friends
but maybe you wouldn't know right and i
think that's where
uh understanding how the entire company
kind of gets behind these leadership
principles
and not just you know they're not just
like in a mission statement but
uses them on day-to-day basis to
actually drive decisions
and solve any kind of conflicts i think
that really
is helpful
right i think i think i would have told
my younger self
to uh learn how to disagree and commit
early in my career
i was the you know people pleaser maybe
it was that military background of yes
yes you know
whatever you want um and i think i would
have
i would have done better if i'd learned
that sooner um
and i think the other the other aspect
is think big
i i think very early in my career i
wasn't thinking large enough and i could
have had
a much broader impact across the
industry if i thought big from the
get-go
right yeah i i i think i would
it would be the other thing i would tell
myself as well
yeah along those same lines
yeah along those same lines i think
starting out especially when you're
given a task or an item to do i was very
like okay i can finish this but i wasn't
thinking so much about why are we doing
this what is the intent
and i think i would have told myself
like it's try to think about that
question first
um because that will really help you
think big and build a better picture and
build a better product as well
right we have um
a question in the audience that says
what is the toughest part of running a
huge service
and the most rewarding i bet you all
have great answers to this
who wants to go first
i'm gonna say i'm on call today so
that's probably the toughest part of
running a big service
uh you know and you know we have
customers
all over the world in multiple regions
and
everything is a little bit different so
uh keeping current with all the changes
in a in a big global organization and
the changes that are going on with our
with our customers
um is is a challenge but it's also part
of the reward
um you know being able to help customers
you know going through cobia 19 and
having to rapidly scale up
or in some cases rapidly scale down
because their business dynamics was
changing
you know it was really rewarding when
they called and said i need help
and we were there to help them
yes yeah i was going to say kathy you
would have a great answer for that
it's definitely a tough part of the
service you have all of the customers
and their requests their bug
bug reports coming in you have your
features that you're trying to develop
at the same time
having to manage and prioritize all of
that um and this
as a service we're very customer
oriented so
um the the work that we put in there
is it's tiring it's it is tough
but it is again very rewarding seeing
the impact that you have
and when you have customers that are so
happy that you're able to help
solve something for them it's really
gratifying to see that
yeah what about as a platform service
having to prioritize requests from
lots of different customers and figuring
out
what goes into which release
any thoughts on that
it's a tough one right it is it is and
you know what uh we have the concept of
one-way doors and two-way doors
and sometimes we we make a priority call
and it's not the right
one um and we have to uh
you know come back to it um you know
and and admit that we're wrong and and
change it um
i like that our roadmaps are driven by
our customers and we do
prioritize them based on what we're
hearing
and you just mentioned something kathy
that's such an important mechanism
um not just in prioritization but also
how to go
fast right this one-way door two-way
door
mechanism which jeff talks about in
his letter to the stakeholder in 2016 he
talked about
what are some of the things that
companies can do
to maintain the velocity
and one of the things to maintain
velocity is that you can't
just make high quality decisions we also
have to make high quality decision
fast and one of the ways we we do at
amazon
is to use through this lens of what's
the decision
that once you make it's very very hard
to roll back
and that's the one-way door you know
kathy talked about and true adore would
be that
you know if you're a b testing um a page
uh whether the button is green or blue
you can always sort of roll back that
and for those
uh decisions we should be able to make
those really fast so that's a really
great mechanism so thank you for
bringing
that up
yeah i think one of the questions i
think
is about that parallel technical and
manageable tracks
and i think we have both the candidates
we have a principal engineer here
and we also have a manager uh so maybe
tatyana
and you give nick you can talk to those
how you went from
an engineer and grew into a principal
engineer
and as well as you took a managerial
role
so i've actually switched between
manager and engineer roles few times
and the best role actually varies by
company and what i find
great about amazon is that as a
principal engineer
i do have a lot of influence and i can
help a lot of people
um whereas like in other companies
oftentimes
to just be in the room and know what's
going on and
help influence like future priorities
and things like that
i had to have manager as like
in my title so here as a principal
engineer or like senior engineer
you do participate in a lot of
discussions you have
a lot of influence so like i would say
that if you are
really passionate about helping people
then like manage your position is the
right fit for you
if you are like if you like technical
challenges if you are super excited to
code something
and like have it working then
engineering role is benefit for you
um as we talk about challenges of
running large services or like rewards
for me it's like any time i do something
where
there's a regression in the product or
like some
something that customers are not happy
about i'm just like
trying to overthink and
just like what could have done better
and like that goes to tiffany's impasto
syndrome yeah i have to deal with that
but on the other hand when i release
something
and sometimes it looks like a small
thing to me but to customers
it might be like very very important
and it's like it's a great feeling
knowing that you've helped
like that customer unlock that deal
like help people scale and get more
value out of the service
yeah thanks the only thing i would add
is that
in my experience we're super flexible
and supportive
of your choice i see or not
and back to kathy's point earlier it's
not a one-way door
decision to go from a developer role to
a management lead
i've had people this is you know i don't
really know i you know i really love
my ic role i want to you know i can see
myself being that but i also kind of
want to try the management rule kind of
want to
exercise the muscle until i've exercised
it i don't really know
and so we actually support people that
want to
do that you can go to a development and
management role
and later on you can switch back to ic
i've known a number of people that have
done that
how to do that you do want to make sure
that you keep up with the technical
you know skills and you're still
practicing the craft but
we're very flexible yeah and i like that
all of the managers
in aws they are also very technical so
it's not just about the people
management they're involved in the
design decisions the the products the
services that were launching the
features
um so i liked the technical aspect but
for me personally i was also really
interested in the people aspect too
so luckily as dorothy was saying i i was
able to try the path
of a manager role and there are plenty
of people on our team as well who have
gone through management and decided to
move back to ic so i love that we have
this flexibility here
good um
if there's no more questions from uh
from the audience
um oh actually we do since i know that
aws engineers own things
end to end more so than other companies
what new hat did you learn or have to
put on
for your current role yar business
this is also a good one
well for me personally i joined a
database business without a database
background
and i was the customer voice to the
customer
on database issues so i very quickly had
to learn my sequel
um and and how it works and behaves
so for me it was not
like that i needed to learn something
because i've
worked at the startup and in startup
organization you often wear
like all the hats when they are writing
documentation next day you are
like on support calls or helping
like sales team so and i actually really
like wearing those multiple hats because
doing the same thing over and over again
like
becomes boring and i like being able to
like work across organization and help
like
in whatever area people need help
would you also say because you know one
of the things that's different about
amazon
is that because we don't just say hey
you're an
engineer writing code is all you do you
don't get to really own a product
and and we really think of an engineer
as someone who's because you're so close
to customers as well
that you should be able to you feel free
to actually really
work with product managers even
sometimes write a pr faq
um to get an idea through and for me
that's super empowering it means that
you alone can make a huge difference can
make a disproportionate amount of
difference here than anywhere else
that is true yeah um
how have you leveraged allies to help
you navigate your career
who wants to take it
well i wouldn't be at amazon if i
haven't leveraged some of my
my allies and uh my network to to get
here
so um i i think it's always very
important
um you know at whatever stage you're in
to both
you know reach up reach out reach across
um you know i've just met three more
people that i'm gonna be
you know adding to my i can reach out
and ask questions so uh
you know when i hit you guys up you'll
know why
so you proactively reach so you sounds
like you proactively reach out
to them i i do because you you never
know
when you're going to need it um you know
for example this week i was working an
issue related to
networking and you know there was a
couple of people i knew that had joined
an area of the networking organization
and you know i was able to connect to
them and they got me the right person to
help me with our issue
right so everyone's busy if you don't
reach out to them proactively
right yeah exactly it definitely
helps me to have my network of people
that i can reach out
sometimes with technical questions but
other times just
to get energy like when i'm afraid to
think big or like challenge something
and like as i talk to them like
oftentimes they get they provide the
support that i need
so that i'm i feel more confident and
brave like doing
that thing that i was afraid to do
yeah i think that's a great thing i
think amazon has this
mentorship network right and we
encourage
each individual even whichever stage
your career
is to actually actively seek out
um mentorship um you know outside of
your organization for specifically the
reason
that you are talking about right you may
want to present an idea to your manager
or your leadership
but you just want to separate eyes on it
right you know
which you know you're not directly
judging it but you are able to kind of
give a
you know separate opinion it could be
technical opinion it could be a manager
another manager and you actually i know
folks who have multiple different
mentors for specific
different uh you know lead help with
leadership principles or aspects
and i think that really helps um to have
those kind of mentors i have a couple of
mentors outside of
the organization um sometimes you know a
previous managers
whom i have worked with and i think
that's the great thing about amazon even
if you move out of a
a team and i would reach out to the
manager who i just left and went
somewhere else and say hey could you be
my mentor and you know
most hundred percent of the time that
usually the answer is yes
the people care about you here then they
actually
take active interest in your career
growth
because when you are in amazonia and you
are looked at as an asset to the whole
company so we hire for amazon
um so and i think everybody has a very
good interest in helping you grow
and you know i actually have a good
example to
like talk about mentorship so i joined
amazon in september last year
uh and i knew that i wanted to help grow
like more women to grow and overcome
like some of the challenges that we face
uh and in october like a month after
joining
amazon i wanted to set up mandarin
circle
and i i like both one-on-one mentorship
and like circle where a group of people
meet together
because oftentimes in these group
discussions
like more people get value out of that
conversation
and it's a great way to build your
network so
in october i was afraid i didn't know
what exactly
like i'm doing but i just knew that i
need to move forward
so and i found uh another mentor
to partner with me and we have a group
of women that meet once a month where we
help each other we discuss
like how to deal with different
situations where like maybe you're
afraid to speak up in a meeting or
somebody took credit for the idea that
you presented
or you're trying to make career
decisions and it's like such a
supportive community
let's talk about our latest recent
questions
i love this question live work
life harmony what does work-life harmony
look
like to you and how do you know if you
have been successful at striking this
balance
or harmony so it's such a relevant even
more relevant today than ever
okay well for me i i actually have a lot
of
extra curriculars a lot of hobbies that
i do um so normally
uh i'll do triathlons i participate in
musicals and
in community theaters and i love to
dance
so for me i i have my dance classes and
my schedules after work and sometimes
that helps me
like say this is the cutoff and that's
where i make the separation of
i finished my day and then i can move on
to dance
and that also helps me take my mind off
things and
gives my gives my brain a break so
that's something that i really enjoy
that helps for me
yeah and you know my my family lets me
know when i'm out of balance
that's how you know very clear yeah they
they
they are very outspoken when they say
you've been sitting in front of that
computer since six o'clock this morning
it's it's time to move yeah so
those of us have children um will know
what our children always tell us
the truth there they they do they do
um but but they also you know
let i mean i think amazon's a great
place that gives us the
opportunity to make sure that we're
having the balance and i have people
that
you know have a one-year-old at home and
with no child care
you know the husband and wife are
trading off and so
you know hours and days that they're
working has switched
and you know it's not unusual for us to
hear some
some child in the background we've had
happy hours you know across our team and
everybody brought their kids in
so you know there there are benefits to
that as well and i i think the key to
the harmony is to recognize that my
harmony
is not tiffany's harmony um but you know
we we need to recognize um what works
for us and
and how to make it and not to be afraid
to tell our manager or our teams etc
um and and also to to check in you know
if you see somebody that's that's out of
balance you know
letting them know and making sure that
you can help them is the best that we
can do and i like how amazon
allows that flexibility
yes specifically you know during kobe
times
right so we had uh as a manager
i have had conversations with my team
and my managers have
had conversations with us and in
specific cases we were able to make
accommodations
you know there were you know couples
working with
children it or at home and in eight hour
schedule
exactly nine to five would not work for
either of them because they have to kind
of you know chop up their schedules so
some of them
are able to you know watch their kids
and we were able to be flexible
in those things and amazon basically
kind of provided some guidelines and
principles
and some of my developers reached out to
me and said i cannot work from home
anymore i need to go to office
you know some of them had cabin fever
right and
you know amazon made it available so
that you had the
place you could go to you have to follow
the social distancing masks and
you know the the precautions but there
were principles set in place so that
people can actually go and work from
work
um if they needed to so i think it's
super important during the kobe times
and i think amazon yeah provides a
support
i think especially you know i think
leading with empathy
is so important during this time um
what i appreciate also is at amazon and
we don't
have so many rules per se but so as a
result we're quite flexible
and so we allow teams to make a lot of
arrangements so on my team for example
we've decided to change all our meetings
from an hour to 45 minutes so we're not
just go from one meeting to another
i know many other orgs as much as well
as mine have also done
mental health days um which i think
everyone appreciated
that so once you know why you just need
that extra day when everyone takes up
you don't have to worry about emails
coming in
so we very much care about that work
life
harmony and and i myself have two
girls they're first grader going on
second grader
and um fifth grader going to middle
school
and so and they absolutely have no
disregard
for when i'm in a meeting and they'll
just come in and so
i always see that as well with my
colleagues so it's
it's it's something that um i think
we're
we are absolutely it's absolutely
accepted and the key
to kathy's point is really to be able to
set your boundaries to be able to also
you know having that trust with your
manager with your team to be able to say
hey this
time that i set for myself or for my
team and
um and and and be able to
um respect that boundary
so we have a question says what advice
would you give to young girls about to
pursue a career in tech
a timely question indeed
so my girls i also have two daughters
at 10 and 13 years old and
the advice that i would give them is
actually
think like sometimes there's this
perception that
tech careers are not for girls and like
it's challenging
but i actually find it like one of the
best careers because
you can work from home like you're able
to have more flexible schedule
and like as we talked about work life
harmony like what is important for me
is to be able to take a break when my
kids have some performance at school
or like i remember i i was taking breaks
when my kids
were like just few months old i was
still breastfeeding them
and just being able to set up schedule
that works for me
is like awesome and you often can have
that flexible schedule when you're
working in tech
versus like if you're working in some
like hospital
like store like there are a number of
places where you have like specific
shifts and
it's more difficult to achieve the work
life harmony
and also it depends on where the uh the
child is uh obviously the young girl is
in the
age-based communication so one of the
things i found helpful talking to young
girls is
uh cast it from an actual user
experience like a customer experience
like for example
you know what i do like if i try to
describe what s3 does or an aws database
does or aurora does
it's not obvious or interesting but
if you cast it in a way of hey this is
the technology that makes facebook run
or a twitter run or
things like that you know it is much
more resonating with them though this is
the one which makes netflix run
right amazon aws makes netflix run zoom
run
all of these things right coming in from
a use case perspective then they find it
you can't watch movies without us you
know there is no amazon prime without
aws so all of these things power those
things
i think that is helpful to kind of you
know uh gain their interest or tickle
their interest
yeah and if you have a very young you
know girl like i have my seven year old
she actually has no stereotype about
girls supposed to do this you're
supposed to do that
the thing that got her hooked into
coding is that she found that she
could do her own minecraft mod she loves
that
she's in this little programming like
these um
now they have these apps um that tinker
is one of the things that she does
and she's essentially using logic to
build these minecraft or roblox mods and
she loves it and so what that gives her
is a sense of empowerment
and i hope that message and that's the
message i
you know i tell her suddenly is that
it's tech is is very empowering and it
doesn't have to be
one thing or another you can use it
to build to create creativity yeah i
think that's the key
yeah yeah i think if we emphasize the
creativity
aspect of it i think a lot of uh i think
uh
young girls are interested in that
aspect you know
yeah we're almost at time
so we can take one more question if
there are no more questions then
we will close the session
by saying thank you very much for coming
and thank you for
um our panelists tatiana tiffany kathy
and anu
sharing your experience we have i think
we have an email list
that we can share if you want to
keep in touch with us but otherwise
thank you for joining us thank you